the world's top companies rely on
analytics for faster and more accurate
business performance analysis one key
area is human resource in which
analytics can be used to optimize
workforce management
by collecting and analyzing critical HR
data companies can generate actionable
insights and improve Workforce people
and talent management performance
hello I am Usha Lenka I am professor and
the head of the Department of management
studies at Indian Institute of
Technology IIT roorkee ranks amongst the
best technological institutions in the
world and has played a vital role in
higher technological education
engineering and research in its 175
years of existence welcome to six months
course on human resource analytics
unlocking human capital program in
collaboration with simply learn this
program will help you master business
analytics and apply them to real world
applications in human resource
management core topics covered in this
program are strategic HR metrics HR
scorecards HR maturity framework HR
analytics framework Predictive Analytics
quantification and measurement tools
along with IIT rorky's expertise simply
learns applied learning approach
combines self-paced e-learning live
master classes from IIT roorkee
professionals interactive doubt
clarification sessions and projects with
24 7 learning support and ample
peer-to-peer interaction with your
fellow learners
some key features of this program are
program completion certificates from IIT
roorkee rigorous curriculum designed and
delivered by IIT rookie professors live
online masterclasses by IIT roorkee
faculty learn by applying through
practical Hands-On training case based
learning specially designed for Mid to
senior level managers and c-suit
Executives this program will easily fit
into your budget and schedule you can
access all aspects of the program from
your home or office
cost for the same is just a fraction of
the tuition fees and expenses of an
equivalent on-campus program what are
you waiting for get in touch with one of
our learning advisors who will walk you
through the application process learn
from the best to be the best
[Music]